steve nick congratulations
the strength of your work coupled with
your competitors failures to perform
have secured you both a place in the
third round where we will send you home
to recreate an iconic blade from history
are you ready to see what that weapon is
oh yeah yep your final challenge is
dear horn knives whoa
deer horn knives are distinctive
double-bladed weapons used as an
extension of the body to counter and
disarm opponents
the knives are unique to the 19th
century martial art form bhagwajang
students of this discipline train with
the weapon in both hands to master
techniques in slashing
and seizing easily concealed in
traditional chinese garb these mighty
knives can be swiftly brandished to
catch an opponent off guard
and deliver deadly cuts with four horn
shaped points
the weapons are notably employed in the
film crouching tiger hidden dragon
i've never heard of a deer horn knife
it's definitely not a design i'm
familiar with
i was hoping for a fairly simple sword
good luck bladesmiths we'll see you in
five days
[Music]
today i start the deer horn knife
i want to make this thing look like deer
antlers
i'm used to making straight pieces this
thing has
curves all over the place and i have to
make two of these things
now i have to figure out how i'm going
to make this
out of this
i want to forge this out of one piece of
steel that's
the strongest way you can do it i'm
going to cut a slit down the center of
this bar
spread the handle and the front blade
apart and hopefully all is going to go
to plan
that looks a lot more like a deer antler
day two so i decided to do a butt weld
i'm like cutting the crescents apart and
welding it flat on so now the edges will
line up
looks very nice ready to do the heat
treat no no i don't want to go in the
fire again
my only concern right now is if this
weird shape decides to warp it all
it could be a problem into the quench
there we go
that is as hard as the file they didn't
warp into a pretzel so
hey i'm great day four
i've got both of these weapons shaped
it's time to harden them
this is the moment this has to work if
it doesn't
i'm not gonna have a weapon
hey no warpage let's see if we got hard
it worked i feel really great
i'm grinding the bevels everything is
coming together
and then i see it uh oh
i've got a crack in one of my blades
that's heartbreaking
it's going through both ends and there's
nothing i can do about it
i've got to test it
i need a pole of some kind i know
they're going to do something like this
[Music]
day five i feel like crap if it wasn't
for the fact that i'm sick i actually
kind of like this deep
gravelly voice if i didn't have to hack
up my lung to do it i'd have it all the
time
all i have left to do is put the handles
on and sharpen the blades
putting the handles on is shaping the
material a little bit gluing them on
drilling the holes and putting the pins
in place to hold everything together
that's all ready to go it's day five
and i have to start over i've got one
day to build a pair of these
i don't know if i'm going to be able to
do it or not
if i wasn't the underdog before i
definitely
am now i just want to have some to take
there i
have three days of work to do in 10
hours
at this point i don't have time for any
mistakes
i just need to stay in the game
bladesmiths to see how lethal your
weapon is i will deliver multiple
slashes and thrust
on this pig carcass steve you're up
first you ready
absolutely let's do this i'm really
hoping to hear
you know it will kill
oh well steve
you know i was surprised being that you
only have a scale
on one side for the handle and none of
the other it is
a rustic look but nonetheless it is
actually comfortable to hold on to
your tips over there sharp enough to cut
easy to thrust
with the bottom and deliver a slice at
the same time overall
your weapon will kill
yeah all right nick you're next are you
ready
oh yeah
well nick your weapon is very sharp
grabbing your handle
it feels smooth with both scales in
there the angles you have
really lacerate deeply and overall your
weapon will
kill good job thank you next up
is a sharpness test to see how sharp
your weapons are
i will take your weapons and deliver
multiple slashes and stabs
on this ballistic bag the bag is
outfitted with two posts which simulates
blocks or blows from pole weapons these
knives will encounter in battle
steve you're up first you ready yes i am
well steve the points are sharp they
lacerate cleanly
it feels good in the hand i can maneuver
this sir will cut
thank you nick you're up next you ready
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm pretty confident mine can do at
least that well probably better because
my points are more pointier
well you can see that it penetrates deep
the angles you have them in
and lacerates out they're comfortable in
the hand and your blades
will cut thank you next up is strength
test
tape to test the strength of your
weapons we're going to clamp them into
our contraption back here
once triggered a staff will strike the
center section
of each of the blades one time with a
force of two thousand pounds
simulating the kind of attacks these
weapons could historically encounter in
combat
steve are you ready yes i am three
two one
in three two one
yeah well steve i don't see any damage
any rolling of the edge
so they held up beautifully that's great
nick just waiting for it waiting for it
and one two three
and it broke the stick three
two one
[Music]
and it broke the stick again all right
well first off let's remember that the
test wasn't about breaking sticks
it was more about how your blade reacts
to being hit by that stick
there is no damage whatsoever this is
still a razor blade
oh nicely done it thank you well you've
both done commendable work but there can
only be one forged and fire champion
in this competition
[Music]
nick congratulations you are the forest
and fire champion
steve your weapons did not make the cut
dave will explain as doug said i really
commend you for
for doing what you did on such a
compressed timeline thank you in the end
it came down to
the fact that the the scales aren't
quite on there's gapping there's
still some marks from where you cut the
steel open and that's why we're letting
you go
i understand steve it's that time please
surrender your weapons congratulations
i'm not surprised at the result there is
a
natural energy that guides all of us
throughout our lives
and this is how everything naturally
unfolded
unfortunately it didn't go my way this
time but
but i'll be back
nick congratulations you're the fortune
fire champion and we'll be receiving a
check for ten thousand dollars how do
you feel
pretty darn good awesome good job
brother
that's me that's me the nick that's me i
won
i'm going to hug my wife when i get home
and then i'm going to hug my kitty cat
if any of you other bladesmiths out
there are thinking about it and i say
do it try not to have a cold when you do
it though
you